[Applause]
yes how you doing Happy Wednesday
America have a mint
now we all know the story of the boy who
cried wolf I'm assuming you're old
enough to have read that story before it
got canceled for animal cruelty and
transphobia
now we're in the middle of a similar
Fable the media who cried Trump ever
since that guy came down as escalator
and beat Hillary Clinton like the rented
mule she is
the media has treated him like Hitler
times 9 11. which is weird because
unlike Hillary he didn't kill anyone
you know the whole the host is Russian
collusion the p-tape Nazis are fine
people let's drink bleach the moon
landing
and according to the media the walls
were always closing in we got him this
time we tweeted Hollywood nitwits like
Rob Reiner almost every week you know
when the only things closing in where
Meatheads arteries
they staked their reputations on
bringing him down and if America had to
fall to bring down the Donald they were
cool with it too but now Trump gets
arraigned and the media can't turn up
the volume anymore they already went to
11. they already blew out their speakers
to use a common biblical phrase they
already shot their wad
that is biblical
Leviticus now now they're finally
getting what they want but it's hard to
care and they fail to see that they gave
Trump the weapons to fight back by
accusing him of so many things that
turned out to be false so now do
supporters care do they listen the Dems
finally think they landed the great
orange whale and it turns out they're
the real Moby Dicks
I mean who believes them they lied to
and insulted almost everybody and those
that keep at it they seem weird like a
stalker
the response that we've seen in polling
from Republicans
suggests that they're going to stick
with them that it's more of a cult than
a political party at this point and
they're going to stick with their leader
Hillary you want to know the prime
symptom of a cult
when the cult leader exploits his power
to have sex with nubile followers
[Laughter]
yep he was the original crooked
so I've heard
look what Trump persecution fatigue has
done to CNN they once had a decent
reputation but now they're like Will
Smith at a comedy club they have the
Smoking Gun but they're amazed that the
bullets are they're firing only bounce
off
we watch Donald Trump attempt to turn
his arrest and indictment into some sort
of campaign commercial we need to
remember that the reason we are watching
this is because Donald Trump is accused
of breaking some very serious National
Security laws the folks in the control
room I don't need to see any more of
that he this he's trying to turn this
and he's trying to turn it into a
spectacle into a campaign ad that's
enough of that yes and that CNN did
enough of that I have total respect for
Jay Tapper but why does his face always
have that look like he's walking behind
Gerald Nadler
yeah
sorry Jake but you want the worst how
about those who do not intend to carry
these remarks live we do not intend to
carry these remarks live
um as we have said before in these
circumstances
there is a cost to us as a news
organization to knowingly broadcast
untrue things a cost
I seem to remember when untrue things
was her nickname the presidency is
effectively a Russian op we're about to
find out if the new president of our
country is going to do what Russia wants
this guy kill him keeps turning up again
and again Constantine Constantine
Constantine collimnik Constantine he's
still Russian military intelligence if
you subtracted all the untrue things
from that this is what you'd have
and yet she's a respected gatekeeper of
information so what's Trump have to say
well last night on the eve of his 77th
birthday at his golf club at Bedminster
Jersey he slammed Biden and called the
indictment a heinous abuse of power
before eventually discussing the boxes I
wondered did the boxes have all types of
personal belongings many many things
shirts and shoes and everything these
boxes were
containing all types of personal
belongings many many things shirts and
shoes everything
fair enough but I wonder if he hadn't a
chance to go through all the boxes
because it's a long tedious job I hadn't
had a chance to go through all the boxes
it's a long tedious job takes a long
time
which I was prepared to do but I have a
very busy life I've had a very busy life
they make it more busy because you're
always fighting true
we all have busy lives maybe Biden can
use that excuse to explain why he forgot
he had classified docs and a
granddaughter
fire yes great fire yeah and you know it
wouldn't be a proper Trump event if he
didn't come up with a new nickname for
someone I wonder is the prosecutor in
this case a thug the prosecutor in the
case
I will call it our case is a thug I've
named him deranged Jack Smith
I wonder what his name used to be Jack
Smith it sounds so innocent doesn't it
Jack Smith what's his name Jack Smith
he's a very nice man that does sound
nice doesn't it but is he behind the
scenes guy and is his record absolutely
atrocious
he's a behind the scenes guy
but his record is absolutely atrocious
later Trump actually handled DJ duties
playing Tunes from his iPad hits
included Blue Suede Shoes and Hound Dog
by Elvis maybe future setlists could
include It Ain't Me Babe by Bob Dylan or
MC hammers Too Legit to Quit
or maybe jailbreak that might be fun but
the sheer fact that he's having fun
reflects the way the world is to him a
video game where he meets the challenges
it's though it's a game it might be
incorrect but it works I wish I had that
frame of mind
and the next time I'm in court I demand
the same sketch artist Trump has I mean
look at that
I'm sorry that guy has to be on Donald's
payroll
he makes Trump look like Tarzan went to
Brooks Brothers
that jawline so now what Will trump be
the first ex-president to go to jail and
will carry Lake bake him a cake with a
file in it will Joe Biden be in a Cell
next to him that's if he's even still
standing upright by election day or will
president Kamala laugh like she's doing
whippets every time she's in public
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and to my Divine mind family
I don't know what she's laughing at her
record I guess
pretty weird the charges sound real but
it's clear their importance is being
inflated and why because they can't say
what they're really doing that the
Democrats are arresting a political
rival that's what it is they're taking
him off the table after targeting for
years it's funny Joe Biden suggested
he'd make sure Trump wouldn't be running
again we just have to demonstrate that
he will not take power
by if we if he does run I'm making sure
he uh under a legitimate efforts of our
constitution does not become the next
president again remember that
yeah he didn't say beat him in an
election he said make sure he doesn't
run I guess this is what this is what he
meant
[Applause]
she was a woman in men's locker rooms
before there were men in women's locker
rooms posted the Michelle Tafoya podcast
Michelle Tafoya
he's not a baker they call him that
after he killed a man with a loaf of
pumpernickel
former CAA operative Mike Baker
the odds of keeping her quiet are like
her dress size extra slim Fox News
contributor captain
here we go there's a severe weather
warning in the northeast or maybe he
just sneezed my massive sidekick in the
NWA World Heavyweight Champion
terrorists
foreign
we'll talk about that later all right
the thing that bugs me about this whole
story is that I think we're all
exhausted by this whole thing and we all
want it to be over with but that's the
strategy and I resent the strategy I
resent the fact that the strategy is to
run people into the ground whether
they're Trump supporters or Republicans
so you just say ah give me DeSantis I
can't deal with this crap and that that
or or I don't know what it is but
they're they're playing on they're
trying to run us down and I sometimes
feel that it's working well I think you
feel that way because it I I it is
working look they the Democrats
do uh messaging very well they stay
together and they stay on message and
you know they they've kind of been given
this gift because honestly what Trump
has done is a self-inflicted wound right
and he's had a series of those over the
years but by that I mean he didn't have
to be in this position right this is not
a difficult thing to not hold on to
classified documents when you leave
office I mean I know that others have
done it but then just hand them over
when you he could have stayed out of
this mess and the the I should have gone
there and taken him I should well well
we took some yeah um and and we have
some under the seats of everybody here
tonight as a parting gift but I think
the problem for president Trump or
former president Trump now is going to
be that all this noise as you pointed
out this this constant drum beat now is
going to remind all those voters who
didn't vote for him in 2020 but
previously had in 2016. and in 2020 they
were tired of the chaos right I'm
talking about whatever you want to call
them Suburban moms or moderates or
whomever 2020 they were tired of the
chaos the only reason Joe Biden won is
because he wasn't Trump
but I think the problem he's got now is
because of what's Happening he's
reminding all those people again of the
chaos that constantly surrounds his
presidency and I think they're going to
look and go yeah I I really don't want
any more of that I think in one way they
might be reminding of the chaos but also
reminding them of the energy and the fun
you know me Michelle I
I often feel that when they they're
going after Trump they always talk about
the supporters they always feel like
it's a proxy for American voters or half
of them and they made them the proxy by
calling them deplorables so I I I I
think that's part the thing that I'm
feeding off of is that it doesn't really
matter if it's trump it could be anybody
they just don't like us well that's
that's definitely true but I do think
his supporters are continuing to support
him because they are tired of this and
they see this as an unequal application
of the law Lois Lerner Hillary Clinton
Joe Biden Hunter Biden we could go on
with people who have alleged wrongdoings
and we don't hear or see anything about
it yeah Joe Biden has documents in his
garage and everywhere else they talk
about and oh yeah we'll get to that
we'll we'll get to that eventually
there's nothing no urgency to that and
so what this the Trump supporter sees
and what they voted why they voted for
him the first time I was what the hell
like why is there this disparity why is
there this uneven application and I'm
going to stand by the guy who's getting
persecuted here whether he is or not
whether he's guilty or not they see him
as a political martyr and they want to
stand with him for that reason because
they're sick of all this other crap in
the swamp you know I would like to think
cat that if the shoe was on the other
foot I wouldn't do this to like
uh uh Joe Biden because you know I don't
want to arrest a president I think it
would be wrong but I don't think I'm
that good of a person
I think that if we get through this
arrest Jill Biden I was going to say
that she pretends she's a doctor you
know oh Dr Jill that's it what kind of
degree is that I don't even know arrest
Joe Biden yes applaud I want this in the
news
[Laughter]
oh no oh the headline cat Fox News
audience Applause arrest of Joe Biden I
want that
let the record reflect I'm sitting here
looking unimpressed
thoughts uh
thoughts all right well I mean he seems
to be doing okay yeah yeah like my
Baseline anxiety is way higher than his
to indictment anxiety
it is but I mean okay so for this
indictment which I've seen a lot of
legal experts including ones who are
more conservative say that this one
presents a lot more problems for Trump
than the Manhattan one does however to
your point I don't think that most
people really know that because they
have all of this fatigue of all the
other times that these things have been
overblown and to be perfectly honest I
wouldn't know that if it wasn't my job
to read this exactly I I wouldn't be
coming home from my long hard day of
charts and graphs or whatever other
people with normal jobs do from what I
have learned from television there's
like a computer there's graphs there and
then they go like this
yeah that's what my husband does
investment banker that's just like
charts and graphs and a headset hello
the models the q1 whatever yeah
um I don't think most people are using
their spare time to really look into
this so I think a lot of people whether
that's you regardless of what it says
they don't really know the difference
they think it's just this is just
happening again because that's what's
been the case every single other time
yeah so I don't know where it goes what
I do know is that if I think I'm tired
now oh boy yes yeah yeah all right Tyrus
bring us home
men can't be careless they just can't
yeah and unfortunately and here's the
cold part it wasn't like President Trump
was carrying the boxes out the office
himself yeah having loading up the truck
and having Eric and then put it in for
it and Vana wasn't driving it like this
is this is poor Staffing there's a staff
guy somewhere going man I I thought I
said Declassified you know but the the
ugly thing is and today I was on a
Falker focus and I I noticed that the
things that they hate about Trump that
President Trump is rude he makes fun of
people he goes after people they do the
same thing at a higher level right they
non-stop do it right so I brought it up
I said where's the decorum right where's
The High Ground where's the teachable
moment for the Democratic leaders over
this indictment and stuff and I had the
biggest troll attack ever because they
wanted to bring up everything that Trump
has ever said well that was supposedly
what you stood against yes that's what
you were there so here's your
opportunity you are exactly you're worse
than him because he's honest you claim
to be these things but you're not and
the thing with the indictment if they do
get to a chance to they're not going to
stop but at the same time he cannot stop
running for president he has to see this
through even if he's in a jail cell yeah
he has and it has to be Republicans that
decide it's over with him if the
Republican party goes with DeSantis it
needs to be done by us not them so you
stay in it till the end hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else